ce soir le peuple français est le comme
président de la république
emmanuel macron il fois plus bas je lui
portais des couilles jusqu'au bout et je
vais coller quels sont les cinq revues
pour cent ont bien voté pour cet homme
c'est quoi la france que vous voulez
laisser à vos enfants c'est le france
dévastée jagland et toutes ces
célébrités avec toi
aussi tu es dessus toutes les célébrités
qui ont appelé à voter pour lui je vous
je vous en tous aux boulettes ou même
une chèvre
alors moi je vais laisser ramous bonsoir
à vous remercier de faire un bon soir
laurent fontaine merci d'être là pour
c'est ce que ce que je te vois tout cas
est ce que je veut nous dire vraiment ce
que tu as sur le coeur vrai c'est comme
une vidéo est ce que tu veux faire voilà
ce soir nous faire ton coup de gueule
qu'est ce qui se passe ravoet sans
crainte dit nous tous
je pense que les gens n'ont pas mesuré à
quel point les français étaient en
colère en fait je pense que certains
sont amnésiques il y'a que la vérité qui
compte mais moi je vais vous dire la
vérité je vais vous apprendre à compter
les erreurs que emmanuel macron en fait
magnol macron c'est quand même là encore
je crois que ça a été déjà décidée par
les français hier soir d'accord ok mais
j'ai eu quand même vous expliquer un
petit peu pourquoi est ce que les gens
sont en colère donc les gens sont en
colère parce qu'en fait macron c'est
quand même le mec qui a épargné des gens
non mais arraché des mains non mais
c'est important de l'êta mais la
campagne est terminée alors madame
géraldine maillet si je peux parler
puisque vous avez le monopole de la
parole et que chaque
parler du débat c'est le parlais déjà
derrière mon téléviseur j'en ai marre
d'entendre la voix de géraldine maillet
couper tout le monde donc si je peux
continuer jusqu'à la fin ça serait
génial merci beaucoup madame et regardez
moi dans les yeux pour me parler et
pourquoi vous pensez que
je vais du harcèlement comme si non je
suis agacé parce que je suis en colère
j'ai droit
donc il ya un moment où il faut arrêter
de faire semblant de pas comprendre les
français je pense que votre président en
tout cas c'est le mien aussi les je le
regrette c'est comme quelqu'un qui a
fait beaucoup de mal qui est méprisant
qui a insulté son peuple il a insulté à
plusieurs reprises les gens ne se
sentent pas représentés par lui ne se
sent pas proche de lui donc vous vous
avez quand même dit que les électeurs de
marine le pen étaient tous des racistes
c'est ça j'avais j'ai dit ça mais la
corvette vos copains disent que je les
dis ouais j'ai dit que s'ils sont mes
copains je suis dans le grille-pain qui
sont mes copains à tous les gens qui
font le même boulot vous sur ce même
boulot que moi youtuber tic toc heures
qui chauffent les gens à danser faire la
promotion marchés agricoles non je n'ai
pas dit que les corps étaient assis j'ai
l'habitude de dire que les électeurs de
eric zemmour était facho j'ai dit il ya
parmi les électeurs de ces deux partis
des gens qui sont de vraies elles aussi
des fascistes
fois ça n'empêche que dès maintenant là
il ya déjà des tricks qui part qu'en
disant fontaine traite tous les
électeurs de marine le pen de facho vous
êtes habitués c'est pour ça qu'on ne
peut rien dire vous avez en colère en
permanence adacore series et moi je dois
avoir le monopole de la parole dans les
médias alors non plus que moi en tout
cas moi
et
avec la version marocaine du covan
c'est fou c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose avec les jeunes sur
le terrain ce que j'ai vu non mais celle
ci a été très grave je comprends mais
moi je peux pas comprendre qu'un mec
effet une fausse c'est pas une vie à
beaucoup de français qui sont dans le
même état d'esprit que vous mais le
conte propose d'autre que la démocratie
pour répondre à tout ça parce que hier
en fait finalement là les français ont
choisi un programme démocratique qui
permettent d'élire un président de la
république qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de
mieux à même de le battre en cinq ans si
on veut d'accord mais moi j'ai quand
même le droit d'utiliser ce même système
qui est la liberté d'expression pour
exprimer ma coloc
moi je voulais savoir ce qu'on peut
faire de mieux je reste que la
démocratie non mais je respecte le fait
juste la présidence ramon et moi
j'aimerais revenir sur ta vidéo tu
parles des articles complets à voter mac
mois leur dire ce soir ben je pense que
tous les évadés fiscaux dubaïote devrait
s'occuper de faire des placements de
produits non frauduleux et arrêter de
demander aux français de voter pour
quelqu'un alors qu'ils sont un pas sur
le terrain ça serait déjà pas mal les
autres personnalités discutent et les
personnalités ou ok j'aurais voulu les
entendre pendant le mouvement des jeunes
qui porte un petit peu leur corones et
qui viennent nous nous dire que le
peuple souffre j'ai entendu franck
dubosc ce qui s'est pris dans la gueule
c'était en inactivant une acception est
inacceptable ce qui était inacceptable
voilà j'aurais voulu les attendent à ce
moment là je suis c'est trop facile une
fois que le drapeau c'est d'aller dans
le sens du drap un jeu vous auriez
préféré que ce soit marine le pen c'est
une vraie question
qui soit hier j'ai peut-être pas lancer
ma vidéo lors du premier tour mais lors
du premier tour j'étais dans un état je
pense que vaut mieux que je ne lance pas
cette vidéo et que je n'ai pas lancé
parce que si je l'avais fait vous auriez
dit quoi j'aurais dit des choses
franchement choisir entre la peste et le
choléra je préfère un vol commis dans
tu sais qu'il ya quelques années quand a
commencé sur sur youtube j'ai même
partagé parfois certaines de tes vidéos
début on s'émeut croisé une fois je
t'avais dit mama halte est un personnage
quand même que tu as fait btp amour des
balances ton poste etc il a un talent et
le vrai problème c'est que tu fais
partie de cette génération et de plein
de gens qui sont pour certains des jours
où ce que j'appelle des gourous sur
youtube ce qui pèse 4 500 milles avec
que des gens qui répondent que ce qu'ils
ont envie d'entendre et c'est accéder à
qui ce ne sont pas des moutons sont les
éveiller en eux ils savent la vraie
vérité est que ces gourous là
vous avez brillé pendant la crise qu
vide ça que ces deux ans de passer vous
en février et font en sorte que vous
n'avez même plus un pet de respect pour
quelques règles démocratiques donc quand
tu traites macron d'enculés hier soir
dans ta vidéo qui sont les gens ça tu
l'as dit revanche que certaines vidéos
qui sont les gens qui ont voté pour cet
[ __ ] le problème c'est qu'avant mais
il ya un truc qui s'appelle la
démocratie dans quel pays tu as vécu ça
j'avais vécu ailleurs en france 1 en
juin je conseille mois il arrive de voir
j'ai 60 ans j'ai l'âge est ton père j'ai
beaucoup voyagé y'a pas un système
démocratique plus fort qu'en france
quand ça n'existe pratiquement pas à
part en allemagne et c'est un sens à un
moment donné respecte au moins la règle
du jeu quoi non mais je veux changer
dans cinq ans tu peux pas simplement
quand le truc ne ta range pas d'accord
dire je veux casser le thermomètre
démocratie j'y crois pas non non il va
revenir là dessus dans un instant ramos
puisqu'on va continuer marine le pen
aurait été élue hier soir et dieu sait
que j'ai tout fait pour qu'elle ne soit
pas à ma petite place eh ben tu sais
quoi j'aurais respecter le choix des
français hier soir et je dirais pas que
c'est une [ __ ] comme tu le dis je
dirais pas que je hais la raison cirer
de ce pour ça que moi je voulais
vraiment m'excuser et je voulais dire à
emmanuel macron vraiment que on compte
vous emmerdez pendant cinq ans et c'est
vraiment très affectueux il le sait
alors on en convient c'est que vous êtes
prêts à chauffer le monde et a bloqué
mais moi je voudrais dire ce soir on
continuera bien sûr à parler politique
dans cette émission a parlé voilà
beaucoup moins maintenant parce que
l'actualité ce sera moins là dessus mais
c'est vrai que en tout cas ce que j'ai
aimé mois dans nos émissions et je le
redis et dans les émissions que ce soit
face à barrack que ce soit et pmp je
trouve qu'on a donné la parole à tout le
monde alors il a plein qui nous l'ont
reproché je vous le dis je ne le
regrette pas une seconde et je le redis
encore ce soir
j'ai tous les gens qui ont insulté les
électeurs du front national ou du
rassemblement national qui ont insulté
tous les gens qui votaient pour eux qui
ont dit
voilà qui les ont traités de racistes de
facho comme je le dis à chaque fois ici
on ne fera jamais ça pour une raison
bien simple parce que nous on respecte
tout le monde et qu'on n'était pas de
donneur de leçons chacun fait ce qu'il
veut il ya eu 12 millions de personnes
donc quand même voter pour marine le pen
et ces français là et emmanuel macron va
devenir le président de tous les
français donc même ces français là c'est
12 millions il va s'occuper d'eux
j'espère et qui va pas les voilà c'est à
dire ce qu'ils vont voter pour marine le
pen
sont pas des français et ce sont des
gens qu'il faut respecter comme je le
dis à chaque fois nous on a énormément
de chance ici voilà on est très heureux
on est content on a un très beau travail
on a une famille on a on est on a la
chance de bien gagner notre vie et il ya
des gens jouent dit qu'ils sont dans une
souffrance extrême donc que ce soit
marine le pen que ce soit emmanuel
macron c'est emmanuel macron qui a été
reconduit pour cinq ans je pense que
vraiment la principale
la priorité sa priorité ça doit être
vraiment d'aider ceux qui le 10 du mois
je leur dis à chaque fois ne savent plus
ce qu'ils vont faire ne sert plus qui
vont donner à manger à leurs enfants et
que à noël prochain ils puissent aussi
acheter des cadeaux pour leurs enfants
et pouvoir aussi profiter de la vie il
ya énormément de gens aujourd'hui qui
survivent qui ne vivent plus et ça c'est
plus possible donc voilà donc vraiment
je vous dis ici on ne traitera on ne
changera jamais personne chacun fait ce
qui lui plaît chacun vote pour qui il
veut voilà aujourd'hui il ya eu un
résultat c'est emmanuel macron qui a été
élu président et pour ceux ceux qui ont
été sur qui ont voté pour lui sont très
contents ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour
lui sont moins contents et maintenant il
va falloir qu'on soit tous dans la même
direction c'est je pense pour pouvoir
avancer et tous les gens qui contestent
le vote qui disent on va essayer de
faire des actions je pense vraiment que
c'est pas la bonne solution au contraire
je pense qu'il faut qu'on essaie
vraiment d'être tous ensemble maintenant
il y en a qui sont très heureux il y en
a qui sont heureux mais c'est pas en
étant les uns contre les autres qu'on va
faire avancer le pays donc là je pense
qu'il faut essayer voilà d'être le plus
soudé possible et c'est vrai que voilà
elle s'occupait des des gens qui en ont
le plus besoin et c'est vrai qu'il ya
énormément de gens en difficulté je
pense que les 12 millions de personnes
qui ont voté pour marine le pen sont pas
des fous sont pas des racistes se sont
pas des gens voilà qui veulent le cas où
ce sont juste des gens qui ont envie
qu'on leur parle on se tourne vers eux
et qu'on les entende voilà c'est tout
donc seulement qu'on les entende mais
qu'on les écoute aussi ramon que je
pense que c'est ce message là aussi que
voulait faire passer parce que ramos on
sait très bien voilà ramon se sait pas
c'est pas un garçon qui peut être
traitée de 2 de raciste de voilà donc
ramous il est juste comme tous ces
français qui sont en détresse il voit là
c'est la détresse des français surtout
il la voit et il la ressent sur les
réseaux sociaux il se dit un moment j'ai
envie de jouer envie de bouger c'est
sarah moi moi cette vidéo j'ai faite
parce que si j'ai pensé oh à tous ceux
qui se sont abstenus d'aller voter ça je
pense que ils ont largement contribué à
ce que le deuxième tour soit en ligne un
ras-le-bol chez moi je ne juge pas ne
pas ceux qui sont pas allés voter je te
le dis il ya aussi un ras-le-bol les
gens ils ont lit de façon il ya
tellement de gens qui se disaient de son
s'est jouée d'avancé puis en aucun cas
il ya des gens il n'ya aucun des deux
candidats qui ne leur plaisait qui sont
dix mois emmanuel macron il qu'on ne
correspond pas marine le pen ne me
correspond pas écoute la meilleure chose
que j'ai à faire c'est d'aller faire un
tennis ou de rester chez moi qu'ils en
soient derrière quoi
le problème c'est qu'on a vécu cinq ans
où il ya eu énormément de mouvements
sociaux il ya eu les gilet jaune manu
les en suisse max a eu énormément de
gens qui sont sortis dans la rue
moi j'en ai voulu aux gens qui sont
sortis 3 400 mille personnes qui ne sont
pas bons tu dit énormément de gens qui
sont dans la rue je donne le chiffre
c'est au plus haut de la vague 3 400
mille personnes dans les rues je fais du
factuel tout simplement on sait en
danger les gens 3 400 milles comment
pendant les généraux 3 400 mille
personnes crise non pas dans toute la
france
500000 mexique pour contrôler c'est déjà
boxer il s'avère épais qui compte vous
c'est pas son problème c'est que dans un
débat ya des gens qui nous écoutent à la
télé la suite vous savez jamais qui a
raison vous savez ce que vous faites
vous des citoyens vous allez regarder
pour regarder sur internet vous faites
deux patients et nous verrons qui a
raison qui a tort
je conteste pas je dis pas cabaye en
ouvrant à rien ne dit pas énormément non
c'est comme les gens qui disent ce
président et et essaient par tous les
français mais il a été élu par six
français sur dix hier n'ont pas un jeune
ans qui les séparent
béatrice alors déjà il n'a pas été il a
été élu moi je conteste rien du tout
voilà il est président et c'est bien le
répéter voilà pas été élu si froid non
mais moi je je il a été élu par pas par
six français sur dix il a été élu par
six français inscrits qui se sont
exprimés sur 10 ce qui ne fait pas du
tout six français sur dix ensuite juste
deuxième point pour revenir ce que vous
disiez sur l'eau plus haut de la vague
céder 300 mille personnes ce qu'ont fait
ou 400 et 500 même si vous aviez dit 500
pardon mais on est dans un pays où il ya
plus de 10 millions de pauvres où la
pauvreté s'est accrue pendant son
précédent quinquennat selon les petits
frères des pauvres il ya cinq cent mille
personnes dans ce pays en situation de
mort sociale vous savez ce que c'est la
mort sociale c'est des gens qui
appellent la poste pour leur demander de
les appeler une fois par mois pour voir
s'ils sont pas morts seuls chez eux vous
comprenez il n'y a pas que 300000
personnes en colère alors sur sur les ou
sur les le début du mouvement les
manifestations réunissent entre 800 6000
personnes et un million cinq cent quinze
mille sont 6000 chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur et un million et demi
chiffres de la cgt
les gens qui sont sa première série sont
exprimés en tant que j'ai les jaunes
mais il ya énormément il ya des millions
et des millions de gens qui sont
mécontents qui sont en colère donc je
vous en prie ne méprisez pas ces gens-là
de minimiser les mines moi je ne sois
pas pour me défendre la politique bien
sûr j'ai voté pour lui il y avait le
secret un premier tour 2e tour
maintenant il ya plein de trucs que je
lui reproche c'est un truc où ses palais
ses mythes il s'est expliqué là-dessus
on peut gueuler on faire les
manifestations on peut voter aux
législatives
moi j'invite tous ceux qui sont pas
d'accord là allez voter france à celui
d'assurer je suis la reine j'aurais pas
le dire allez voter marine le pen allait
voter zemmour au moins vous exprimer
quelque chose moi pardon tu vas pas avec
ton bulletin de vote et larmes
démocratique le dimanche moi j'y suis
allé pourquoi pourquoi d'autres n'irai
pas c'est un acte important de voter
quand même et a7 a plein de pays on vote
pas dans le monde et les pays on se fait
tuer j'ai abandonné va voter si tu veux
pas accepte le principe de l'aluminé
gens l'impression que les dés étaient
pipés que les tout
deuxième tour
cyril arrêté c'est un rendez vous que
tous les logements non je mélange pas
les rendez vous que les français en
étant des jauges fini juste mon bolide
est subjugué je finis oui parce que
votre président a voulu faire de débat
jaccaud venu expliquer en fait déjà la
campagne avant le deuxième tour il y en
a pas eu ce serait dans ce message ses
projets dont il est président
mais il est triste de l'europe je vous
me posez une question je voudrais plus
sûres je ne veux pas revenir sur les
bases c'est pas le sujet de ce soir je
voudrais passer un bac s envoyer c'est
vous qui a trait à l'or mais si on me
demande ce que je voulais dire non moi
ce que je ressens de l'extérieur c'est
qu'il ya énormément de gens qui
souffrent mais il ya un ras-le bol parce
qu'on ne sait pas où aller on savait que
marine le pen n'allait pas passer c'est
un peu comme le psg va toujours en
finale elle perd tout le temps donc faut
arrêter de le psg va finir par gagner
je te dis c'est l'adéquation des goûts
j'te lille n'a pas fait de campagne il a
refusé tout débat mais c'est faux c'est
maintenant elle n'a pas fait débat
mais c'est fou il est il la mamounia
attendez je venais d'apprendre c'est
grâce à ma ba face à bah c'est un fait
ce qu'il n'a pas fait face à baba qui
l'a pas fait campagne non mais je viens
que j'ai dit ça veut dire à siri
qui l'a pas été au contact contre
l'américain des émissions obtient 2
le fusing débattent 2e open alors
reproché en 2002 il a fait face à bah
[Applaudissements]
c'était un rendez vous beaucoup de gens
attendaient beaucoup de gens même des
gens qui n'aimaient pas les missions peu
importe beaucoup de gens attendaient
cette émission parce que pendant 5
pendant ces 2 puis les gilet jaune c'est
quand même cyril qui a donné la parole à
beaucoup de gens sur ce bateau là et je
suis bien placé pour savoir j'étais avec
lui sur balance ton post je suis là
comme en séries mais je sais très macho
était là dans les coulisses donc je sais
très bien ce qu'il fallait ce que je dis
c'est que c'était un fil conducteur
c'était peut-être le rendez vous
beaucoup de français attendaient des
français qui ne s'intéressaient pas
décevant mais c'est pas pour autant que
c'est une injustice oui tu vas sidéré
que les dés sont pipés les world series
faire face à marat ils ont pu ils ont pu
montrer leur programme et leur
personnalité de marine le pen et jean
luc mélenchon avait tous les deux des
chances d'être au second tour c'est
marine le pen qui est passé au second
tour c'est marine le pen qui a perdu la
finale et valérie pécresse mesquine à la
2 millions d'euros de dons
ton coup de gueule on le voit tu étais
extrêmement là on va le revoir c'est
vrai que je me tenais vraiment ce qui t
lire en fête
ce soir le peuple français est le comme
président de la république
emmanuel macron une fois plus bas je lui
portais les couilles jusqu'au bout et je
vais coller quels sont les 58% ont bien
voté pour cet homme c'est quoi la france
que vous voulez laisser à vos enfants
c'est le france dévastée
s'implante et toutes ces célébrités à
toi
aussi tu es dessus tout les célébrités
qui ont appelé à voter pour lui je vous
je vous en tous on voulait tous même une
chèvre tous auront alors tout sauf
macron ouais ça a été ma croûte merci
jean voter jean luc mélenchon omar de
sescoi la barre des mots de haine ils
sont des gens qui éructe comme ça pardon
excusez moi pense que les gens ils en
ont marre finir des soins ses deux
filles et les femmes noires yc rade à
mon fils comme le ml prince à leurs
enfants j'ai un enfant j'ai deux faisant
fendre montre de ton âge et bains les
bains pardon l'a suivi dans lequel gens
utilisent ce n'est pas la tienne et ben
manuel où on et rubin moi je vais
désormais en encaissons l'ailé
principale est située fait mon père je
t'aurais dit franchement va pas bien je
suis
serrier hugo c'est ton frère mais ce que
le dire il ya beaucoup de gens moi avant
de venir j'ai reçu plein de messages de
soignants qui m'ont dit on va travailler
avec locaux vides on est dans la merde
il ya des soignants qui sont vu virer
ses décors vides y en a déjà dix ans et
j'ai le temps va être vais je voudrais
dire c'est que si on enlève le crachat
et les termes excessifs de ramous sa
colère elle est réelle et je trouve que
laurent vous faites preuve d'une
certaine condescendance à l'égard de
l'expression de cette colère ben oui
mais vous agitez la main voyez vous et
ainsi faire ça et je trouve que laurent
vous n'écoutez pas la colère dire que
oui mais je vois votre ictus j'aimais le
président est plus modeste que vous
aussi écouter la colère parce que sinon
bah oui mais voilà vous avez aimé mais
c'est énervant parce que vous allez y et
ce qu'il dit je fais aucune nous
devenons par et se répondent et pardon
en quoi qu'est ce qui te permet de dire
que je n'écoute pas la prière comme tous
les français j'ai écouté cette colère
comme tous les français j'ai vu les jo
dans la rue et comme tous les français
pardon on sait quand on fait de la télé
mais que le barça tu fais là telle
espèce de nantis machin tous ceux qui me
connaissent savent que je suis dans la
vraie vie que pardon il y'a que la
vérité qui gronde j'ai des followers
guesdon qui me suivent c'est des gens
qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent qui ont
des problèmes qui m'ont pas jeanine télé
populaire donc le peuple je le connais
gérer mieux populaire donc le mot peuple
je le connais alors tu es posture à deux
balles tu les gardes c'est pas la
posture serono met à la faute et une et
couperait la connaît c'est maintenant
17 jours sont les électeurs ce qui était
là mais ce qui est important c'est que
ça soit emmanuel macron qui écoute la
colère et je viens seulement de trouver
qu'il n'a pas fait preuve de
triomphalisme
hier